ونحييكم من جديد الاتفاق على استئناف
العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران بعد محادثات
اجريت في بكين تاتي بعد سبع سنوات مقاطع
الرياضه العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بطهران بعد
هجوم على السفاره السعوديه في العاصمه
الايرانيه طهران والقنصليه في مدينه مشهد
في يناير من سنه 2016
حينها دعت الرياض البعثه الدبلوماسيه
الايرانيه المتواجده على اراضيها لمغادره
البلاد خلال 48 ساعه معتبره اعتداء على
السفاره والقنصليه السعوديه في ايران يشكل
انتهاكا صارخا لكافه الاتفاقيات والمواثيق
والمعاهدات الدوليه وموضحتا ان تاريخ
ايران مليء بالتدخلات السلبيه والعضوانيه
في شؤون العربيه ودائما ما يصاحبه الخراب
والدمار
اعود من جديد الى ضيوف بعد قليل
هي نتيجه لمحادثات استمرت لسنتين وصلنا في
نهايتها الى تفاهمات مبنيه على حسن الجوار
واحترام سياده الدول ومعالجه كافه تحديات
الامن الاقليمي من خلال هذا الحوار وان
قناعه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان الحوار
هو الاسلوب الانجع الى معالجه كافه الامور
نتابع هذا النقاش مع ضيوفي
وسابدا معك معالي السفير فهمي في الواقع
نحن انطلقنا بالتذكير لماذا انقطعت هذه
العلاقه في 2016 على اثر الهجوم على
السفاره والقنصليه السعوديه واليوم في هذه
الاتفاقيه الجديده ايران تتعهد بحمايه كل
المرشات الدبلوماسيه السعوديه في داخل
الايراني هذه الجزئيه تاتي ضمن اتفاق اكبر
كما تعلمون حضراتكم وهي اتفاقيه التعاون
الامني التي تشمل العديد من النقاط الاخرى
من بينها مكافحه الجريمه الارهاب غسيل
الاموال مراقبه الحدود البحريه والمياه
الاقليميه يبدو بان الطريق طويل هل تعتقد
بان ايران جاهزه لاحياء مثل هكذا اتفاقيه
اعتقد
وايجابي
للغالبيه العظمى من دول العالم وخاصه في
الشرق الاوسط في معاهده دوله واحده
من مصلحه ايران لانها تحتاج لحوار مع
الدول المجاوره ومطلبها دائما كان اتحاول
مباشره وليس من خلال الدول العظمى
التقليديه وبشكل خاص الدول العظمى الغربيه
فهذا حقق لايران مدخل للحوار
هناك
ايجابيه تجاه او بالنسبه للجانب السعودي
جانب السعودي دائما يطالب بالحوار انما
يطالب بالالتزام بمبادئ معينه تم ابرازها
في الاعلان ولا هي عدم التدخل الشؤون
الداخليه وهناك ايضا التنويه بالاشاره الى
اجتماعي وزير الخارجيه بتناول السياسات
العامه للبلاد في المستوى الاقليمي وان
هناك تحفظ سعودي مشروع اجابه محاولات
لهيمنه الايرانيه في الشرق الاوسط المتحده
الصين بطبيعه الحال
يبرز نجاحها الدبلوماسي وهذا
جانب ايجابي لها المتحده في اعتقادي مرحبا
بالاتفاق ايضا لانها لا تريد التسعيد
المبالغ فيه تجار في تصعيد غير مبرر تعتقد
ذلك فعلا مع للوزير
تعتقد فعلا بان واشنطن من مصلحتها هذا
التقارب حتى وان كانت تصريحاتها ربما تدعم
في شيء ما ولكن مصالحها الكبيره في
المنطقه قد
تفهمنا غير ذلك
انا معك انما انا بتكلم على هذه خطوه هذا
ليس تحالف ايراني سعودي باي شكل من اشكال
هذه خطوه نحو تهدئه الامور فمن صالح
الامريكي تهدئه الامور لعدم التصعيد
المبالغ فيه الخطوه الثانيه لها تقييم اخر
الجانب الاسرائيلي متحفظ طبعا اتجاه هذا
والحكومه الحاليه تلوم المتحده وتلوم ما
سبقها والحكومه السابقه تلوم الحكومه
الحاليه نتيجه للتصعيد الذي شاهدناه هذه
خطوه انما
النجاح او الفشل
يتطلب اقوال ايجابيه ثم افعال ملموسه
وتثبت التحرك فانا اؤيد بالتاكيد هذا
الاعلان وايد تدرج المطروحه فيه دول
مبالغه لا اقلل على الاطلاق من صعوبه
النجاح الكامل اعتقد ان سيستغرق وقتا
طويلا وانما هي خطوه ايجابيه ومفيده
للاطراف الثلاث بالتحديد نعم دكتور
هاشميان صحيح اكيد اكيد مع الوزير دكتور
هاشميان اليوم ونحن نتحدث هناك امر واقع
لا يمكن اخفائه فرضته ايران هناك هيمنه
على عده دول حتى وان كانت هذه الدول ترفض
طبعا احتراما لسيادتها ترفض ان يقال بان
هناك هيمنه ايرانيه ولكن ايران نفسها تقول
ذلك ايران نفسها تصرح بانها تتدخل وتؤثر
هيمنتها هذه تمكنها من السيطره على ملفات
عديده كيف لايران ان تنسحب او ان تتراجع
عن هذه الهيمنه لصالح احياء تعاون امني
باي ثمن ما الذي سيدفعه لذلك
اولا هذه الهيمنه لم تعطي شيئا
للمصالح الوطنيه الايرانيه طبعا اعطت لي
الشعارات
الحاكمه نقاط ولكن كانت مكلفه جدا
سياسيا دبلوماسيا اقتصاديا للشعب الايراني
ولذلك نعتقد ان في حتى في زمن الهيمنه
وحتى في زمن ان هناك كان بعض الجنرالات في
الحرس وبعض المسؤولين المتطرفين في ايران
كانوا يتباهوا بهذه الهيمنه هناك كانت
معارضه قويه من داخل بعض الاجنحه ومن داخل
بعض التيارات في داخل ايران اما تيار
اصلاحي ام فراق ماتي وكان يحذر من هذه
الموضوع اولا لم تاتي بنتيجه نهائيه يعني
ايران لا تستطيع اطلاقا وابدا ان تهيمن
مطلقا على هذه المنطقه بشكل كامل ونهائي
بل هي في الطريق الهيمنه وعليها ان تدفع
ثمن جدا غالي لهذه المحاولات ولهذه
الحركات ولو كان هناك الصراع دائما بين
موالين ما يسمونه في داخل ايران بالميدان
او ساحه المعركه كان رئيسهم في تلك الاونه
قاسم سليماني وايضا هناك كان من يتحدث عن
موضوع الدبلوماسيه وحسن الجوار مع الجيران
خاصه الدول العربيه في المنطقه وكان يتمثل
هذا التيار بمحمد جواد ظريف وزير الخارجيه
وهناك نفس الصراعات بين هذه القوه حول هذه
الهيمنه ولكن الان كما يبدو
في ظل الظروف الجديده وفي ظل الوضع
الاقتصادي المنهار واحتجاجات شعبيه واسعه
وبالمناسبه الشعب الايراني يرفض كل هذه
المسائل الهيمنه في المنطقه ولذلك الان
الظروف هي مواتيه لاجيب الاخر لانه يعطوا
فرصه
للدبلوماسيه ليتحركوا في اتجاه دول الجوار
في اول خطوه
للمصالحه مع الاغليم والمصالحه مع الجوار
ثم بعدين يتجه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وسمى
الولايات المتحده في ملفات اخرى انا اعتقد
ان
هذه هذا الموضوع تم تجربته ايضا في زمن
محمد خاتمي عندما طرح حوار الحضارات واراد
ان يتوج حضار الحوارات بقضيه الامنيه مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الان هم عليهم
ان يعيدوا هذا الطريق والان الظروف مهيئه
ولكن طبعا هناك ستكون عقبات ستاتي من
المتشددين وستاتي من فيلق القدس استاذه
جاسر ما راي حضرتك في هذه النقطه هل تعتقد
كضيفي بان الوقت سانح لان تتراجع ايران عن
سيطرتها خلينا نقول او تاثيراتها الخارجيه
هو الدكتور هاشميان لا يود كثيرا باستخدام
كلمه هيمنه لا يرى بان هناك هيمنه حقيقيه
لا اعلم ان كنت تختلف او تتفق مع حول هذه
الجزئيه ولكن هل تعتقد بانه فعليا الوقت
سانح بان تتراجع ايران لصالح الداخل لصالح
ترتيب مصالحها لصالح ترتيب اقتصادها لصالح
ترتيب علاقاتها دوليه خاصه
اعتقد
بشكل واضح اتفق مع الدكتور حسن انه صحيح
يعني ايران دفعت كل فعاليه في مساله
الهيمنه لكن احدثت خرابا شديدا في الاقل
في اربع دول عربيه وتمكنت من التعطيل
لكنها لم تشكل لها قوه لم تشكل لها طموح
الذي كانت ترتجيه في ان تكون مهيمنه هذه
الدول الاربع معطله يعني سوريا دوله مدمره
وليست سوريا دوله متحركه بالتالي لا تشكل
امتيازا لايراني الان هل تستعير ان تتراجع
وانا والله على المستوى الشخصي اشك اشك ان
الهيدروجيه تخرج يعني ليست هي حاله
انفلونزا تمر يوميا وتعدي اتوجه مترسخه هل
تغير الاشخاص هل في يوم وليله اعلى نور
براءه من هذا المساله نعم هناك تهديد
وجودي داخل ايران يضغط عليهم حاليا وهذه
هذا الاتفاقيه هي مخرج جميل
للنظام ويعيد له يعني فرصه تنفس مره اخرى
استنشاق الهواء في مرحله جديده هل اذا
استنشق والسعاده الراحه والطمانينه سيستمر
او سنتيم مثل ما انت تتفقد خاتم
وتبخرت وعدنا الى نقطه الصفر نامل لا يقول
لانه الخيار محدود نقول لعل الايرانيين
الان النظام الايراني عفوا يدرك انه مصيره
يعني مصيره الداخلي ليست تهديدات الخارجيه
مصيرهم من الداخل اصبح يعني مخيفا ويعني
قاتمه جدا فبالتالي يستوعب انه هذه
المساله تغيرت هل هناك هل هناك قوه داخليه
في النظام الايراني اليوم استطاعت ان تعدل
المعادلات هل هي الراحه المراوح التي تاتي
فتره خاتمي مريحه والحضاريه والمرنه
والمتعاونه
لن يعني لا توجد صوره بالتالي لا نراهن
المملكه على فكره لا تراهن ولا تضع
الاحتمالات هي تضع تدرس الوقائع وتتعامل
على اساسها فتح هذا الباب وتحقق ولذلك
يشير الى نقطه مهمه قالها ترى الوزير
مساعد العيبان في كلمته قال بعد شكر
ونامل على ان تواصل مواصله بكير لدورها
اللي هو الدور الضامن
ان ان بكين ستصير هي خطوه خطوه تتابع ما
يحدث
وهي تراقب الاداء الايراني وايران اذا خلت
بهذا الاتفاق طبعا بتخسر السعوديه وبتخسر
المنطقه كامل لكن ايضا استخسر شريك مهم
جدا يعني دعمه وسندها وقف الى جانبها
ويفتح لا افاق مستقبليه اللي هو الصين
وستخسر ايضا روسيا وبالتالي المخاطر عاليه
جدا لكن ماذا ستفعل ايران هل ستتخلى هل
ستحول الى ملاك بين يوم الليل لن تتحول في
الملف اليمني
نحن لطالما كنا نسال عن ايران ولكن ماذا
عن السعوديه يعني اليوم نعلم بان هناك قبل
ان اذهب لمعالي الوزير فهمي ساكون معك فقط
في نقطه استاذه جاسر اليوم نعلم بان هناك
ملفات جدا شائكه بين الطرفين ونعلم بانه
اول
اخفاق ان صح التعبير او اول عدم القدره
على استكمال بناء هذه الثقه قد ينهار على
اثره او تنهار هذه الاتفاقيه الجد مهمه
السعوديه هل تفكر على المدى البعيد بمعنى
انها هل يمكن المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان
تتنازل عن بعض الملفات او اجزاء من ملفات
لحسابات اخرى لحسابات قادمه تعتقد
لا لا اعتقد لا يمكن للمملكه ان تتنازل
بمعنى انه اذا كانت تحدثين تسويات او
صفقات يعني
خليني اقول لك انا انت تتساهل مش ان
تتنازل ان تتساهل انت تتساهل ان تمرر ضعف
النقاط لصالح مثلا مدى متوسط الى بعيد
لا في اشكالات صعبه نقول انه معالجه
الميليشيات في العراق تتطلب وقت طويل
والطلب جهدا ايضا هناك ملفات طويله شائكه
ومعقده ولا تتخلى ايران بيوم الليل لكن
تعيد ترتيبها بشكل يضمن انه تحقيق
الاستقرار وعدم التدخل في الدول ترى هذه
النقطه الوحيده التي نص عليها البيان اللي
هو عدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه والدول
لا يقصد المملكه فقط تقصد المنطقه ككل
فاراد هل استوقف ايران عن التدخل في الشان
البحريني هذا خطوه ضروريه هل سيتم معالجه
الملف اليمني بشكل عاجل هذه خطوه ضروريه
ندخل في الملفات التي اكثر تعقيدا
وبالتالي هذا شان الدول عشان العراق عشان
يسوريا عشان لبنان لكن تعمل ايران على ان
تنسحب ولا تكون عاملا سلبيا ومن خلال
التواصل وبالتالي احنا ندخل الان في مرحله
تمحيص هذه هذه الشهرين فتره امتحان حصه
امتحان نتيجتها تطلع اذا كانت لديك
ايجابيه فتحت السفارات وبشر العمل واذا
كانت نتيجه سلبيه او مرت ابتكاسات فيعني
ندخل في مرحله اخرى من الاحتمالات
والتخرجات والاجراءات الاخرى على كل انسان
نكمل هذا النقاش ساعود لك بعض لحظات معالي
الوزير فهمي لنحاول كذلك ان نستغل حضورك
معنا للاستفاده من خبراتكم العمليه
والمهنيه حضرتك كنت وزير خارجيه سنتحدث عن
استخلاص الدروس كيف يمكن استخلاص دروس
الماضي للبناء من جديد بطريقه اكثر صلابه
اعود لكم بعض لحظات ضيوف الكرام
نتوقف مع فاصل من بعده سنعود لنتابع
هل سيتكرر سيناريو 2001 عندما فشلت اتفاق
المشابهه ستستفيد كل الاطراف من دروس
الماضي
[موسيقى]